an art can be a potent storytelling tool
in anime in just a few episodes a series
can deliver some of its hypest plots
complete with or inspiring action and
heroic moments if you look at it and are
just one small part of a big whole but
this small segment has the potential to
make or break a show a poorly executed
art can make the viewer lose interest
and give up on the show entirely the
Shonan universe is full of arcs that do
an exceptional job of telling a story
effectively and compellingly so today to
commemorate this channel reaching the
very important milestone of 600,000
subscribers yes I wanted to do another
very special and personal video for you
yes I'll be picking 10 of my favourite
shounen arcs in anime this is also in
keeping with my policy of picking just
one entry per series okay but on that
note let's get started
[Music]
we kick off this list with bleaches soul
Society Ark this one is a given and
perhaps the reason why bleach reach the
epic heights it did before it's
inglorious fall from grace before it
went off the rails at bleach was the
core kid on the anime block with the
potential to become one of the greatest
shown in shows of all time and the soul
society Ark is where it all started it
gave us unforgettable characters like in
and Meyer II it had incredible battle
sequences think it's ago versus Kenpachi
or Renji versus byakuya and it left us
with the smartest most deceptively
badass villain the soul society arc did
all the heavy lifting setting the stage
for Bleach to do something incredible a
pity it didn't turn out that way though
isn't it but that moment at the end of
the arc when Aizen snaps his geeky
glasses in half and drops his good guy
facade remains a brilliant legacy of
this fallen giant remember the heavens
arena and hunter exam arcs from hunter
hunter
well this entry on the list is from
Takashi's other notable work YuYu
Hakusho
and i feel it far surpasses both of them
the dark tournament saga follows the
protagonist a you skate or a mushy as he
and his friends enter an underworld
contest where they're pitted against
killers and demons spread across 40
episodes it took almost a year to air
when an arc lasts that long
there's a very good chance of it losing
its way that too when it's mostly all
matches and battles but dark tournament
doesn't falter at all on the contrary
for me is the show's best arc the
battles are intense but the pace never
gets too frenetic thanks to some quiet
moments in between the story shows that
use gaze growth and maturity as he's
pushed to his limits both physically as
he faces freakishly strong opponents and
emotionally as he watches his mentor
fall in battle his ground breaking a
muscle popping final bust up against
togoro has all the destructive power of
a good old 90s anime as an added bonus
togoro makes quite the impression as a
multi-layered villain who's so much more
than his awesome crew car and rippling
muscles
[Music]
next is the final arc of Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood from the world of
martial arts we move on to a universe
ruled by alchemy by now I'm sure you
know the story of Edward and Alphonse
Elric brothers and alchemists on a
mission to take back what they lost in a
disastrous failed experiment brotherhood
explores some dark themes loss sacrifice
the limits of humanity this is also true
of its final arc the chief attraction of
which is the battles between the
homunculi and the Elric brothers and
their allies the fight between Roy
Mustang and MV is particularly memorable
because it goes beyond the flame
alchemists impressive takedown of the
shape-shifting homunculus this battle
between hero and villain good and evil
explores one of Brotherhood's dark
themes to great effect the theme being
that nothing is completely black and
white at the end of their contest we see
Mustang so consumed by hatred that he's
on the verge of turning into a beast
himself on the other hand every is
resentful longing for the undying human
spirit makes the homunculus a little
human at some level all in all the final
arc has so many great moments from the
last transmutation scene to the epic
final battle if I ever make a top-10 FMA
moments I'm really going to have a hard
time ranking them 7 we have another
tournament arc a very nostalgic one at
that the tune in exam comes in the first
half of Naruto and it's its first big
arc it serves as a test of skill
intelligence leadership battle prowess
and all the other quantities required in
the next crop of ninjas that inhabit
this world the series is known for its
eloquently choreographed fight sequences
and the Chunin exam gives it its first
bragging rights the matches are of the
highest level and highly entertaining as
the young contestants show off their
wildly different skills from shikamaru's
shadow imitation technique to Rock Lee's
taijutsu it serves up some of the best
underdog fights in anime - such as class
clown Naruto surprising the Hyuga
prodigy nage II with a punch to his face
and changing his outlook on life and
destiny or Rock Lee almost getting the
better of a seemingly invincible and
creepy as hell Gaara and making us all
realize that we dig a hard-working guy
in a green jumpsuit moreover this arc
serves as a great introduction for all
the characters who go on to become
central to Naruto storyline teams
the rookie 19 guy Gaara and Orochimaru
let's not forget him as a narc the
Chunin exam is not just a single event
but rather a launchpad for some of the
most important and enduring friendships
rivalries and relationships that make
this anime special
talking about special there's no anime
quite as special as Gintama its first 50
or episodes are pretty much practical
jokes parodies and madcap moment strung
together with a good bit of satire
thrown into but when it's time to get
serious this show gets right down to it
with even lazy odd jobs boss kintoki
turning into the deadly shiroyasha the
farewell Shinsengumi arc is perhaps the
best example of Gintama smooth
transition from goofy to grim I know a
lot of Gintama fans prefer Shogun
assassination arc over this one and
that's that's pretty fair actually
because I feel it's also one of the best
shown in arcs around however my personal
favorite arcing Gintama is the farewell
Shinsengumi arc battles are the
highlight of any serious Gintama arc but
farewell Shinsengumi deals with
weightiest subjects like personal demons
uncomfortable truths and friendships
between enemies the villains are all
highly memorable the sadistic new Shogun
no boo no boo the meme owada gloomy
which replaces the Shinsengumi is the
Shogunate special police force and the
10:00 show in Naraku a shadowy
assassination group that also works for
the government and it introduces us to
su ro the series toughest antagonist
towards the end the emotions really hit
home with the bickering in toki and
Hijikata sharing a last meal Kagura and
Okita fighting one last jewel and of
course the Shinsengumi saying goodbye to
eddo with a promise to come back someday
[Music]
Rurouni Kenshin known to some Western
audiences as samurai X is a classic
shown in show with heavy undertones of
Japanese history this entry is not an
arc from the series but an original
video animation or OVA that serves as a
prologue to it titled trust and betrayal
is the story of how the protagonist
himura kenshin becomes the infamous man
slayer it also reveals how he got his
famous scar both in its imagery and its
story and treatment the OVA has a darker
more brooding tone than the anime series
trust and betrayal doesn't hold back
with this display of violence bloodshed
and gore at the same time there's a
serenity in quiet beauty about it that's
a complete odds with its violent themes
and yet these two halves make a whole
that never feels jarring the battle
scenes make as much sense as the more
mundane moments in Kenshin's life at
home the beautiful background animation
and use of color make these moments
shine even more trust and betrayal is as
much of a journey of a man's descent
into hellish violence as it is a love
story between a man and a woman who were
perhaps never fated to be together if
you haven't watched the OVA I highly
recommend you do even if you haven't
seen the original series yet
[Music]
next we take a look at return to chigan
china from attack on titan no shown and
listing can be complete without an entry
from attack on Titan the show that's
made a habit of upping the anticipation
with each new season
it's the latest arc returned to shegaon
China follows Eren Mikasa and Armin as
they returned to their hometown four
years after it fell to Titans they're
part of an ambitious expedition to learn
the truth behind the Titans and reclaim
war Maria but it's more accurately a
suicide mission
given the waiting for them is a fierce
battle against the beast Titan and
certain death the action is fantastic as
usual Levi's mowing down an army of
Titans and almost killing the Beast
Titans probably the most badass one-man
show in anime but the fights this time
are as emotionally charged as they are
bruising this is especially true of the
clashes between the survey corpsmembers
and the armored and colossal titans the
writing effectively captures the inner
struggles on both sides it does the same
when Levi has given the unenviable task
of choosing one life over another within
the space of just 10 episodes
major characters die a new Titan is born
and an old enemy reveals his hidden
connection to Eren at the end of all
this tragedy and bloodshed the mission
to learn the truth hidden in Aaron's old
basement ends in success but also in
mixed feelings return tsch against
enough for me is attack on titans best
art yet and it raises the bar high for
how the rest of the story will unfold PS
we dig the new Thunder Spears
[Music]
the show posted a classic game of
cat-and-mouse between a serial killer
and an eccentric detective brings up the
rear of our top three shown in arcs the
battle of wits between Light Yagami as
the serial killer Keira and Elle is
legendary and needs no introduction
given Elle's popularity among fans the
animes first 26 episodes is called the a
lark though you could argue in reality
it comprises three arcs the super arc
tells the story of Lights descent into
darkness on finding the Death Note and
meeting the Shinigami ryu k-- Elle's
pursuit of Kira and the battle of
one-upmanship that ensues between the
two what makes this battle a hoot to
watch is the characters of its players
light is a model student on the surface
popular and talented but deep within he
is an evil incarnate a manipulative
killer with a god complex and no remorse
l on the other hand has a slouchy
appearance that makes others doubt his
abilities but he's highly intelligent
meticulous and analytic he's also deeply
suspicious deceptive prone to lying and
not above using cruel and criminal means
to get what he wants the art comes alive
with their scheming and planning as it
is in every battle there's a winner and
a loser this applies to the contest
between light and L as well by now most
of us know how it ends the L arc is not
the end of Death Note but it might as
well be after all I'd say this is when
the series started to go downhill for me
personally but the airlock on its own is
a masterpiece and no one can convince me
otherwise
who
at number two is marineford from
one-piece action adventure ship loads of
cool characters and heartbreak come
together in this arc that one piece fans
will probably never get over as the
Admirals and their allies go up against
the might of the white beard pirates and
Luffy's motley crew the action never
stops for a moment
but these frenetically paced 33 episodes
are more than just the fighting the
marineford arc has some splendidly
written moments such as white bids
fierce last stand and garbs quiet grief
then there shanks who makes one of the
biggest impacts on this arc despite
being absent for the most part of it in
his short cameo we get a glimpse of the
quiet power of this man that we've seen
much too little of so far the marineford
arc takes the viewers through a gamut of
emotions as courage and loyalty clash
with treachery and deceit it will
probably have you hating Blackbeard in a
canoe with a vengeance
not that we blame you for it though of
course but nothing hurts quite as much
as the tragedy that awaits us at the end
in this rollercoaster called one peace
the story of marineford will break your
heart like no tragedy drama ever can
[Music]
what Emily
in the top spot then we have the Chimera
ant Ark from the 2011 anime reboot of
Hunter hunter this shows pretty much the
manual on great story arcs if you've
watched the phantom troop and zoldak
family segments you'll know what I'm
talking about but for me this arc is
undoubtedly the most superior of them
all given the show's track record it
comes as no surprise that the action is
of the highest level in this one maderos
deathmatch with Miriam and guns rage
moment against Pete oh don't have an
equivalent but even in the clashes
between secondary characters the actions
more than skin-deep and crackles with
innovation and personality the hunter's
invasion of maryam's castles more
goosebump inducing than title fights in
some anime in between the fighting there
are moments where the story changes pace
and just breathes a little yet these
moments are just as vital to the
narrative as the boom and bombast of the
fight sequences mara where's shogi game
with kabuki is one such contemplative
sequence while seemingly not part of the
main story it's nevertheless critical to
the change in the ant Kings personality
before he engages the hunter in battle
it gives the ruthless Miriam a
compassionate even human side that we've
never actually seen before it's a
turning point in his evolution as one of
the greatest anime antagonists of all
time the art comes to a
thought-provoking end raising questions
about the concepts of hero and villain
good and evil you gotta watch it to
believe it this arc is the main reason
why Hunter hunter 2011 is still my
favorite anime of all time
and that's the end of this video I hope
you enjoyed watching it if you did give
it a like tell me in the comments below
what's your top 10 shown in arcs in
anime I'd love to hear from you on this
one and do subscribe for more cool anime
content I would like to thank you once
again for helping this channel reach
600,000 subscribers I'm truly grateful I
couldn't have done it without you and
for those of you who haven't subscribed
yet please consider doing it if you
enjoy this type of content and hit the
bell button so that you never miss any
of my uploads stay tuned and I'll see
you next time on Vinny tube
[Music]